she's welcome to simon Sinek so uh Simon
asked if you can make a cameo so you
want to just get up here to do a little
Q&A or I don't know we'll just talk and
have fun right ahead up thank you okay
so Simon just showed up what did you
have another yeah event or something
yeah answer speaking to accountants
sounds fun they were lovely we had a
week and then uh and so Simon said you
would come by for a little bit and happy
birthday everyone yeah twenty years old
[Applause]
I was made okay so yeah we celebrated
last was it yeah it was last week and
twenty years yeah
we're now you've moved from thinking
outside the box to thinking on the
bubble yes when that went over about it
my Joe
what um what made you decide to come say
hi
well I love you guys I mean I mean it's
always a joy every time I get to visit
your office and I talk about you all the
time and I brag about you guys and when
I found out that I was gonna be here and
you were doing this I called you up and
said I want to come and so you can say
you got me a seat so yeah so last last
week we celebrated the result of I don't
know if you saw the video there's all
this confetti and and so on and then I
it was super hot out and there was a 10
and most people in the tent couldn't
hear what I was saying so but part of
what I said was talking about over just
reflecting over the last 20 years I
think if I only learned two things I
think the two most important things I
learned over the last 20 years about
what separates apples from other
companies is number one most companies
don't see their employees as more than
just whatever job position and don't
understand all the potential and talent
that is like there right within their
own organization and then the second
thing I've learned is that most people
actually don't even recognize that in
themselves of the potential to they're
put in those oh yeah you know in the
situation where they have to afford out
they think about how many people define
themselves by their jobs like you know
that you're you're in sales or you're an
accountant or you're a doctor or
whatever it is and then you retire and
you stop doing that and then you people
go through an identity crisis when they
either stop working or change jobs or if
if they lose their job it's like they
have no more identity and I always want
to be defined by who I am not what I do
when I when I give little blurbs and
things for books I always insist that
they call me optimist and author you
know the stuff that I've done has to
come second Who I am and how I see
myself and what I view myself in the
world and it is the thing
that I think is so magical about you you
know you and I are both out there
preaching that businesses need to see
that business is a human Enterprise fun
first it's called a company it's like a
group of people literally and and we
view people simply as as just for their
hands but not for their hearts or their
heads or anything they can contribute as
their as human beings so what advice
would you give to we have visitors from
other companies like what advice you
know we're doing things completely I
can't remember how much you and I have
talked about what we're doing in terms
of market-based dynamics and having a
you know from the beginning my goal has
always been to help employees find the
you know magic wand is every employee
has found the intersection of what their
passion about what they're good at and
what adds value to the company and so I
remember when in the early days that was
when we were fifty or even a hundred
people was very easy to for someone to
and we encouraged this to being saved
working at the front desk wasn't for you
then go try out merchandising yeah that
wasn't for you then and we've literally
had employees be in eight or 10
different departments over their time at
Zappos and but as we got bigger it's not
as easy you need a system to do that and
so that's the goal of market-based
dynamics is to build a system that
enables circles to employees to search
for that intersection what their passion
about what they're good at and what adds
no you the company but it's kind of a
weird system yeah so for standard
hierarchical companies what would you
recommend well I mean look there you
represent somebody who's willing to go
to the extreme to make the point to test
out the theory and you know the other
exactly the other extreme is sort of
unfortunately what is normal in business
today you know where we used mass
layoffs to balance the books on an
annualized basis and we and and and we
rank and yank people and and we all of
these horrible things were shareholder
supremacy all these horrible things is
the other extreme and it doesn't mean
you have to be you know there is a
middle ground but I always think that we
the thing
that we the most the easiest thing to do
for any company is to help people be
their best versions of themselves to
help them be human you know I hate this
concept of soft skills you know we call
hard and soft skills like soft actually
sounds tough you know it's hard skills
and human skills and everybody knows
that if you want someone to do a job you
have to teach them how to do their job
like if you're in sales we'll teach you
how to use the computer and we'll teach
you how to use the phone system and
we'll teach you how to like what our
process is if you're in if you're an
accountant you go get a degree in
accounting and you learn how to do the
job and when we're junior we have to be
really good at our jobs that's that is
our job and if we're good we get
promoted and we eventually get promoted
to a position where we're now
responsible for the people who do the
job we used to do and nobody teaches us
how to do that and so we don't teach
leadership we don't teach the skills
that are required to take care of people
which is all leadership is and the
amazing thing is is regardless of our
rank and regardless of our position
these are skills that we all need
organizations can do bet a much better
job of teaching us listening and
effective confrontation and how to give
and receive feedback and empathy and
patience and all of these things that if
you're going to be a parent you better
start learning them but if you're gonna
be a human being you should probably
learn those too it helps us interact
with each other better with customers
better with vendors better and at the
end of the day we're more confident in
ourselves because we're bringing all
those skills back home to our families
and our friends and yeah and the best
part about it is when an organization
gives that kind of education and
teaching and training to their people
their people the the net benefit is
people feel like the company cares about
them as individuals not as simply
somebody who fills a job function and
that's what breeds loyalty and love for
our companies it's I it's so common
sense like it's it's it's and it doesn't
actually require a lot of money either
it it you can do these things for for a
shoestring budget or sometimes even for
free
it's it's so what would be the next step
for one of the external companies that
are in the audience
right now and what would you suggest for
next step for us to find a book that
teaches these skills and have a book
club where everybody and everybody in
the team reads a chapter and you come
and spend one hour per week do it over
lunch if you like and you talk about it
and and what'll start to happen is
people will start to have ideas and
allow people who have a passion for this
to innovate you know one of the biggest
mistakes companies make is they they
stop passionate people you know somebody
comes you guys
I love leadership I read all these books
I've seen all these TED Talks I've
studied all these companies I would love
for our company to build a leadership
training program I will totally
volunteer to do it they go oh fantastic
what we really need you to do is develop
this training program because you're so
good at developing training programs and
they go okay you know why would you
stand in the way of a passionate person
because the great thing about passionate
people is not only will they do all the
work because they want to and they're
learning but if it doesn't work so well
the first time which it probably won't
they're passionate which means they'll
try again and again and they'll get all
the kinks out and they'll figure it out
and and if you there are passionate
people in all of our organizations who
care about listening and empathy and new
ways to develop incentive programs give
those people a long runway and let them
try things out and experiment on us you
know and we don't have to force anybody
to do it we can ask for volunteers who
wants to be the first to go through
their training program and then early
adopter mindset we're all in it together
we're okay we know that it's imperfect
but what ends up happening is we make
things better and better and better and
better and better and it's all homegrown
it cost zero you know
so one of the things you know I remember
when we were fifty or hundred people and
now at fifteen hundred people I would
say the vast vast majority of sapless
employees are all very well intentioned
if not all of them and so what I noticed
was if I don't think it was anyone's
fault and one of our core values is to
build a team and family spirit but from
the beginning it was about consensus
building and that just doesn't scale
it's just a function of the number of
people in in the structure and so one of
the things that we're trying to do is go
from this org chart that's hierarchical
to one that's more networked and as a
result of that under a hierarchy someone
with the passion you need to get your
managers of all your managers so all it
takes is one no for an idea to get
killed yeah whereas in the future state
all it'll take is one yes cuz any of the
several hundred circles yeah can decide
to you know also be passionate about a
pain idea that yeah I think we you know
cuz I love your thinking and I love what
you're doing and I think language
sometimes gets in the way and we talk
about non hierarchical you know the fact
of the matter is human beings are
naturally hierarchical and it's it's not
a bad thing nobody's offended by it like
nobody is morally offended by the fact
that somebody who's more senior in the
organization makes a higher salary gets
a better parking space we may think
they're an idiot but we don't we're not
offended by the fact that they're given
certain perks or advantages because of
their because of their rank you know and
and in any population we're constantly
assessing and judging and we'll defer to
those who sort of take a more alpha role
and where we are offended is because the
role of an alpha the role of a leader is
to take care of the team is to protect
right the responsibilities of leadership
is is to is to is to take care of those
around us and see those around us rise
and the closest analogy to great
leadership is parenting there is
absolutely a hierarchy in a family mom
and dad are absolutely higher up than
the children and it's not a democracy
you know however okay from the from the
mother in the room right and we all know
this which is parents that attempt to be
equal with their children and attempt to
be their best friends and it actually
fails as a parenting strategy but but at
the end of the day a parent's
responsibility is to love and care for
that child just desperately and that
does it that you can still discipline
someone you can still correct someone
you know all of these still things still
exist and the same is true in any
population including in an organization
where there's still hierarchy so if
somebody says I'm gonna take
responsibility for this project right
this is the team and if things fail it's
on me
there's still a hierarchy and my job as
the leader of the group with the team
whether it's anointed or voluntary is
that I'm gonna see that the team has all
the skills and support that they need so
that our project can be a success and as
the leader I'm not responsible for the
results I'm responsible for the people
who are responsible for the results
yep and I guess to clarify we have this
concept called circles and so what for
each circle I know I know I know your
thing but my boys when we say what like
I when we say we're anti hierarchy what
were you saying
you know Tony asked me before we came
logical just yeah well just Tony Tony
asked me before I came out if if I mind
it if he touched my butt
I was just flattered that he asked asked
asked all right so one joke kind of went
over will and we had one good one they
liked it when I did the running thing up
the up the side which by the way I was
really excited that was spontaneous
because it's a high box and I thought
what a perfect to me while I was running
up the box
this is Cirque du Soleil is staged like
how perfect to do that because there's
always a funny never mind
is it's a circus there's a funny
character so we don't have much time
left but uh
I should I talk about weed stop trying
to make joke you want to talk about our
lunch in New York the few years ago or
you want to talk about something else
sure a few years ago we had lunch in New
York it's fine
I I think I had the salmon and I asked
him why it was a fun conversation I
decided to Tony one I don't know what
his but for those of you don't know he
has a book called start with why and I
actually resisted reading it for the
longest time because because your deck
mostly because in literate you know Jen
our friend Jen and know mostly what she
asked me I was like I could think I kind
of get the idea from the title yeah like
just start with wine so yeah this oh
here's a funny thing a lot of people in
your position and I've talked to a few
who are in your position more visionary
leaders or more sort of evolved way they
think about business and I say do you
know what you're wise they go yeah I
know I'm like well have you ever tried
to put it into words they're like don't
need to there I'm like why like
everybody knows there's this assumption
because it's crystal clear to you in
your gut that it's automatically crystal
clear to everybody and it's not always
well that's why we had lunch together so
so yeah and so it wasn't a formal
session but because you do these
discover your why workshops for
companies humans and companies and and
so we were just talking over lunch and
and he was asked me about my earliest
childhood memory or something like that
and I actually was born in Illinois and
moved to California when I was five but
the only memory I really have is like
catching these fireflies and mason jars
at night and then they say that was like
my portable flashlight and the question
that I asked when you tell me the story
is of all the amazing and wonderful
beautiful things that you did as a child
what do you think was is it about that
memory that stands out to you
what is what is it that makes that
memory why would you even tell what is
so important about that memory that you
would tell me about that now or them
because you asked for the earliest
memory no I know but you'd but there are
many other things that happened and you
chose to tell that one and what is it
about that one that stands out to you
that makes it special I think it was
just the I know like fireflies are
already cool they do their things but
then this was a way of like creating or
inventing in my mind I had invented it
and no one else had ever done that
before and so it was just I know here's
what fun and here's why I ask questions
like that because because how Tony sees
the world and how we all see the world
we are products of our upbringing we're
products of the experiences we had when
we were young that make us who we are
and that it forms our worldview and so
if you Tony when he is at his best and
more importantly the organization that
he that he's trying to help build is he
sees everybody as a firefly he sees the
entire world as people with bright
lights
he doesn't distinguish you know who the
bright ones and who are the dim ones
everybody has a bright light and
everybody's out there doing their thing
and what Zappos is as a container for
bright lights and if you can build your
fire if you can build if you can take
all these wonderful fireflies that all
by themselves beautiful and fantastic
but if you put them in a container where
all of their brightness comes together
you create a flashlight you can actually
light a path for somebody else and I and
I firmly believe that when you are at
your best that is what you are doing
with Zappos Zappos is the jar and the
people that are in in this company which
is all of you you are lighting a path
not only for the people you serve
internally the people you serve
externally but you're showing the rest
of us how a business should be built and
if quite frankly you were doing the
exact same thing now as you're doing
when you were five thank you
I didn't realize that that had so much
meaning and and it now then because of
the why Tonys why is actually the why of
the company and even I debated this it
is now everyone's job that all of you
not only fireflies in the jar that we
call Zappos but every single one of you
has a responsibility to build a jar
yourselves and find the fireflies to put
in whether they're customers you're
talking to and you create a bright light
together or they're federal or team
members and your circles like the
everybody has to take responsibility for
the maintenance of the jar and make sure
that all of the the fireflies inside are
burning bright so we all have a macro or
micro responsibility yeah and the I
think the draft purpose statement that
we came up with by the end of the lunch
was the exact which is something like to
space for creative people to shine or
something yeah like like have the canvas
for people's that unlocks people's
creative in potential and they can
create wonderment I think he used you
came up with one more nice I think we
should use the word light they can
create light cuz at the end of the day
that's you know it's a it's a it's a
nice metaphor that doesn't sound so a
business hackneyed you know with like so
many other terms that go in these things
but creating light is you are a bright
spark in the world of business you know
business is dark and you guys are bright
and it's lovely